the issue of the approximate rate at
which things happen
is common in a lot of science is the
rate at which things fall
the rate at which reactions occur and in
computer science
typical concern about growth rates comes
up in
looking at the efficiency of algorithms
and whether they're growing linearly or
quadratically
or more and we're going to look
today at four notations that describe
relations between the growth rates of
functions
the first of these relations is the
simplest one it's called asymptotic
equivalence or asymptotic equality so
this
uh tilde symbol is read as
asymptotically equal to so f of n is
asymptotically equal to g of n if and
only if
the limit of the quotient of f of n over
g of n
is one let's look at an example
um n squared is asymptotically equal to
n squared plus
n why is that well it follows trivially
by manipulating
the algebra uh the limit of n squared
plus n
over n squared simplifying is just the
same as the limit of 1
plus 1 over n but as n goes to infinity
1 over n goes to 0 so the limit is 1
as claimed those two expressions
or the functions they define n squared
and n squared plus 1 are asymptotically
equal
some there are some easy properties of
asymptotic equality that follow
immediately from the definition
one of them is that it's symmetric
namely suppose that f is asymptotically
equal to g
i want to prove that g is asymptotically
equal to f well what's going on here
let's look at the limit of g over f
which is what i'd like to prove is one
well the limit of g over f by algebra g
over f is the same as one over
f over g so just moving the limit
across the division that's the same as
one over the limit of f over g
which is one over one and we've proved
in other words that g
is asymptotically equal to f given that
f is asymptotically equal to g
it's symmetric there's a similar
argument for transitivity let's just
crank through it for practice on the
definition suppose that f
is asymptotically equal to g and g is
asymptotically equal to h i'd like to
prove that
f is asymptotically equal to h
well again we just plug into the
algebra and distribute limits let's just
look at this we're given that one
is the limit of f over g because f is
asymptotic to g
but f over g can be expressed as f over
h divided by g
over h that's just algebra the h's
cancel
so this limit now i can distribute the
limits to the numerator and denominator
assuming both exist and the numerator
limit
is what i'm interested in the
denominator limit is going to be
1 because the limit of g over h is one
since g is asymptotically equal to h the
conclusion is indeed
that the limit of f over h is equal to
one
this is not really very interesting
stuff
and the top level message is that many
of these
elementary properties of asymptotic
equality
and the other asymptotic relations that
we're going to see
follow by this kind of elementary
algebra and distributing
the limits over sub-expressions
anyway uh the corollary of this is that
asymptotic equality
is in fact an equivalence relation we've
proved it's symmetric and transitive and
it's trivially
reflexive it's an equivalence relation
by the way it's worth noting that it's
an equivalence relation on
functions of one variable when we write
sometimes that
f of n is asymptotically equal to g of n
but we mean that f of n is the
description of a function
f we're not talking about the number
that f n happens to have for some
particular value of f
so while we'll sometimes write f of n is
asymptotically equal to g
of n for descriptive purposes the proper
thing we should be writing is that f is
asymptotically equal to g
asymptotic equality is a relation
between functions
okay the next asymptotic relation we're
going to look at is called
asymptotically smaller than
and it's the notation for it is this
little o notation so you'd write
that f of n is equal to little o of g of
n
if and only if the limit of f of n
over g of n goes to zero as n approaches
infinity
so let's look at an example of that n
squared is little o of n
cubed because trivially the limit of n
squared over n cubed is the same as the
limit of one over n it's equal to zero
and by similar kind of reasoning that we
did for asymptotic equality being an
equivalence relation it's not very hard
to prove
that uh that little o defines a strict
partial order
on functions
so the third relation asymptotic
relation is the most
complicated of the three although it's
arguably the most important in computer
science
it's called the asymptotic order of
growth big o
and the definition is that a function f
is big o
of a function g what it means is
that the limit of f over g is finite
so it's it might be other than zero or
one
but it's finite and that means that f
is big o of g now there's a technicality
there
where the expression actually says the
limb soup
of f of n over g of n let's just ignore
that for now and we'll look at it
uh uh and explain why the limb soup is
there a little later
so as an example 3n
squared is big o of n squared
because the quotient of 3n squared over
n squared is 3
which is less than infinity so what big
o is doing is kind of saying that
constant factors don't matter
and that turns out to be particularly
useful in computer science where
you can't really talk about the time
that a procedure takes because that's
going to depend on the hardware
so when you implement it on faster
hardware
it may grow at the same rate but the
time will actually change
and that's why big o plays a prominent
role
the final relation of the four is called
theta or same order of growth the
definition
of f is theta of g is simply
that f is o of g and g is o of
f and it's easy to show from the
definition that theta
is an equivalence relation so to
summarize
there are these four relations um
f asymptotically equal to g means that
informally that f and g are nearly equal
um f equals little o of j informally
means that f is much less than g
f equals o of g means that f is roughly
less than or equal to g where roughly
means that we're not concerned about
constant factors
and f equals theta of g means that f is
roughly
equal to g and we'll examine these
properties in more detail in the next
segment